subsidies is a zone well it's not it's
not a concept you really know a lot of
fun over here as much as we do subsidies
is a good thing and it's a bad thing
subsidies meant that for a long time and
I'm talking about my own experience in
Germany you had a musical project and
you went up to somebody who had money
usually an official at you know at the
city or state government cultural
departments and you you told them what
he wanted to do and they said yeah cool
here's some money do it and you did not
have to think about an audience you did
not have to think about you know how
successful things would be where it
would be you know where it would be
leading it was just funding the arts
funding something new it was a very la
polla kind of concept of you have to
fund the arts beats because the arts are
important and we are not as politicians
we don't really have a political aim
where this is all this leading are the
only aim is that yeah we are such a
confirmation and this has changed and
actually to be honest I only became I
mean I know this but I only became aware
of it in a couple of talks with a couple
of my colleagues and with my students
here how much this has changed in the in
the years and I believe it has to do
with the fall of the wall that by now
Europeans look well well as I said was
when I going to give this example of
this of the the evaluation guidelines in
and Switzerland and Zurich the cultural
departments in the cities and in the in
the in the different states and
governments actually want something for
their money for the first time this is
actually important I mean it wasn't it
was important was always important but
for the first time this actually people
actually talk about this so they say
well what do we get for this you have to
hand in a report and we want to evaluate
it we want to see what you want to see
what is what good is
doing for us and why is that happening
because though you know after 1989 the
complete market changed in Europe there
are you know the board has opened up
suddenly Europe is competing against
itself for the first time the jazz scene
is competing against other Europeans I
well my example always is from for me
when we produce um when we produce
concerts at the the venue we have at the
jazz incident down step if I invite a
band from Great Britain I get a grant i
get if i get funding from the British
Council it is cheaper for me than to
invite well you know even some German
bands by marketing so all of these these
market mechanisms all of the the change
in the market influence the influence
how European Jets was perceived because
by by the jazz scene becoming more of a
market all the players on that market
also become aware of the fact that they
have something to sell so for the first
time jazz musicians actually young jazz
musicians under 40 actually apart from
seeing themselves artists also see
themselves as somebody who has something
to sell and you know record companies
actually project their advertising at
very clear markets the German ECM they
will did it for a long time the German a
CT label is doing it recently some
Scandinavian labels are doing our really
marketing so the French labels are
really marketing they are really they
they want to open up new markets and
their market is not America their market
is in Europe yahuh man's valent or
German jazz critic and jazz producer
founded the first jazz department at a
public radio station at the root
festival radio shortly after the war in
1945 or
think actually was in 1945 night at
midnight early nineteen forty six and
that became the model for all the jazz
departments of course in Germany jazz
after the war has political connotation
jazz is the music that is the music of
Americans at the music of freedom of the
music of democracy it was a music that
was forbidden for the whole time of the
Third Reich so opening of a jazz
department had extreme political
connotations and the connotations were
were also political for other European
countries because I mean the war
affected literally everybody in Europe
so whether it is Scandinavia or friends
or Britain jazz was the music that spoke
of freedom that spoke of individuality
that spoke of everything that Nazism was
not and so that is one of the bases why
jazz actually went into the radio
stations it never really was questioned
I mean the radio stations in in Germany
and in Scandinavia which are the most
active ones to this day fund concerts
they have their own radio big bands with
some musicians who are on celery until
they retire which is not always a good
thing but you know there is there is a
certain system that it's just there
nobody questions it oh yeah nothing is
as strong as it was yeah yeah well the
private radio is competing against
public radio so public radio is trying
to keep up with private radio so
everything is kind of changing but knock
on wood um while we hope I mean okay
I'll just shortly in Germany we paid we
pay taxes for public radio so it's not
like you you know paying for National
Public Radio because you wanting but if
you own a radio in Germany you pay taxes
for it if you or tv7 Germany you
if you're a own two or three or as an
American six you only pay you only pay
taxes once but you pay taxes and that
those Texas go only to the public radio
they don't go to private radio station
they all go only to public radio they
finance the symphony orchestra that jazz
big band WDRB band and ER big band a
chart big band which are radio big
friends in Germany for instance so they
finance concerts and all of this town so
that is still going on but a lot of
people questioned a lot of people say we
shouldn't do that so I don't know where
it's gone we can't change it I don't
really know whether it's if it is not
good if people and it's especially the
people who market it when I talk to
musicians it's different but if there's
people who marketed get so overly proud
of their achievement and I think there
is something missing because what as I
said you need to have both the respect
of your achievements and Teresa the
respect to where it comes from it is
kind of it is kind of good because a lot
of things are you know I wish you had I
wish there were more maybe I'm saying
something wrong here but I wish them
were there was more competition over
here and i'm not talking about market
competition but im talking about
artistic competition so maybe and
because the scenes are so different from
each other you have the danish scene and
the skill of the whole scandinavian see
in the French see the German scene now
the Polish T in the Czech team the
Italian see in the Swiss scene and all
these are scenes that are company it's
not single musicians or bands competing
against each other but it seems that are
allowed to develop within their scene
and then they compete against each other
so it's a different system than you
could ever have in in a whole country
where you just have one
big scene so is that good I don't know
we have to live with it I think I think
some European say it's good a lot of
Americans say it's bad it will change
some odd will it will change everything
in Europe will change the perception I
don't know where it's gone 2004 me first
I think a lot of musicians in Europe
credited for advancing the regen holla
your like Pierre Grossman they're really
at the barber better go home didn't use
the word jazz and I mean I can't say
they never tell you they like a lot of
reference issues finding just too loaded
and just automatic translation and sort
of slide step of questions who owns it
or is it racially is original or into it
and I think also what I take to be sort
of the root of what you're saying is
that positions on in Europe needed to
find the music themselves that's
rude is no different than what positions
in and I think we have a lot of
musicians in the commercial and less
commercial areas of American guys who
talk about they're still dealing with
the challenges of Coltrane and Miles
Davis as if that's something that you
probably as if anyone except you and
it's in America to its a musician to
find end of themselves rather than just
lean on the tradition who wish to music
or did you actually write as their dad
they buy the world well the question who
owns music that's a good question i show
you i just got that and we didn't we
didn't find out really find an answer
did i just got that in the class i'm
giving I you know I try to as well who
owns music who owns a heart I don't know
so I don't think anybody owns music what
what might be own is a certain tradition
so that's when i'm talking about respect
it has to do with respecting a tradition
now there are people who say well why
don't you call that music you're doing
over there something different why don't
you give it a different name I mean you
kind of made that you know say when he
said they're well some of these
musicians didn't actually call actually
the musicians you you name all call
their musicianship their music chance
Peter Brooklyn Oh Derrick knows we have
Derrick Barry doesn't that's true but
but every Parker he says I'm a jazz
musician peter brian says down with jazz
musician Peter cobalt at one point he
said okay actually I'm going into the
global fee but he always saw himself as
a jazz musician but there are others I
mean I know I know what you're talking
about actually there are musicians who
at some time said well you know let's
not call our musician music giant animal
that's it let's call it free improvised
music thus actually freeing it from all
the connotations and also from all of
the responsibilities towards
american jazz traditions and I don't
know well with their I've certainly
respect a lot of certainly I love derek
bailey i know a lot of musicians in
germany who did that who did it for
other reasons for them the reason was if
you don't call your music jazz you might
have the chance to get funding out of
the pot for contemporary composed music
if you might actually if you don't call
your music jazz maybe the game are the
German S curve will consider your music
so called serious a music series corner
you know not compose but you put into a
different category which pays better and
I know some using musicians who for whom
that was a reason because I know it
because I'm sitting in some of the
comedies that is deciding on about money
and at one point the the jazz
departments had more money again and
then they finally call their music jazz
again because there was where the money
was so it's but that is I mean not taken
away that there yes yeah but who owns
the music I cannot answer that I do not
believe our design Patti buddy
the information I while I tend to
disagree jazz is ok I give you I give
you an example actually I looked at yeah
I give actually I looked at up today
because of what was you know that we
have jazz Appreciation Month there they
have a big poster and it says jazz
appreciation on april two thousand eight
born in America enjoyed worldwide I'll
think about that I mean this is this
it's true and it's not true born in
America yes but it's not only enjoyed
worldwide it is played worldwide and it
is actually developed worldwide because
it's such a creative music so it is
there is another angle to it and and I
guess one has to live with that it is
such a creative music as such I always
call it you know the productivity of the
music is so it's just so exploding that
it's it's a gift of America to the world
I can live with that and because I
dearly believe that and that's what I
believe everybody who's in the jazz
field believes but it is something that
has developed everywhere because
Americans taught musicians how to how
creative you can be with this tool yes
and more
which are included
so there is our
um I didn't gather echidnas get the last
but I have to get a little closer visits
so what was your question exactly yes
yes
actually actually that's a good point
and actually I would yes I would say
that is also part of the respect so part
of the respect is not only you know
saying going up on stage and rephrasing
Charlie Parker John Coltrane or you know
other sound but it is also you know
respect of the lesson learned and I
think that is that is something that I
find very important this lesson learned
because it is a huge lesson and I don't
really know whether even many American
musicians even when they come to Europe
whether they actually realize what they
started over there and what you know
what what how public there the effect of
their their lessons was in Europe I
don't know whether everybody realizes
around yeah hmm I went to I went to a
concert in Italy maybe a year or two ago
somewhere near bergamo and it was all
concert was kind of avant-garde ish but
no actually it was monkish music they
played monk not really monk tunes it was
all original to us but it was in the in
the tradition of felonious monk but a
little more avant-garde than that and it
was outdoors and there were a lot of
blue-haired ladies and I was kind of
wondering what they were doing there and
they were having they brought a basket
with bread and wine and they had a
picnic there and they enjoy the music
and they applauded and they wanted
encore and that would never happen in
Germany or go to France and I see a lot
of young people going to you know music
to two bands they had never heard of
just being curious so there that that is
an inner European there are many many
inner European differences in audience
reactions I come to America and I just
enjoy the the audience participation you
know the way that an audience actually
is part of the Act something that we
lost in Europe you know because in
Europe you go to console you sit there
and you enjoy the evening and then your
plot and that's it but you don't really
you know this this part of this
participatory element that is something
that Europeans miss learned long before
jazz came over
and
I mean that thing in Germany is the
scariest place in the world and that the
audience tears 80 the whole time by the
way you're making the same this is
depression he's very very well oh did he
hear that he told about this Japanese
trumpeter he says German audience are
the scariest in the world because they
stare at you and they have a musician of
the feeling they're waiting for you to
make a mistake they are not but yet they
can be very scary that is that is
actually true that is actually true
because German audiences have been
educated to be Farland and and if you're
coming from culture where you were
you're not expecting a silent audience
that scare can't scare the hell out of
you but I can't really tell I can't
really answer your question because
there are those few instances that you
know I know of Japanese musicians
especially Japanese musicians playing
was with your PM musicians they usually
work within a free jazz context that is
very or free improvisation context that
is very open anyhow and where people
don't really think about you know this
the origin more than they hear this
global kind of coming together so it's
not really something that makes much of
an impact impact
doesn't get the game that he's
demonstrating here he said that he
travels the world left left when he
heard that we don't need Americans and
what we've got on it and I wonder if fun
but he said that it struck him I'll
remember what he said correctly that the
drum and bass seem to be the last
instruments that other countries thought
they could do without their have one
brother commanded continue making an
argument about of any instrument it is
something about the trumpeted robbery
survey is certainly true that especially
American musicians coming over to Europe
in the 1950s and 60s had a hard time
finding risen section so they usually
made you so the same reason section that
everybody made use of which were a
couple of you know you could actually
count them on one hand while needs
tending recipe dozen from Denmark bass
player or pmish shallow from France or
maybe give deep Pattinson also French
basis drummers that's even give more
difficult Alec 30 from Denmark so there
you know it's only a couple of them and
that changed that's changed I mean you
still well to be honest I went to them
when i arrived in new york in january i
went to the lenox lounge on a monday
night to hear on patients higgins and
the door opened and front drama just fun
to me
no no no drummer a drummer I can't I
can't be callous day now walked in well
he's a famous funkerman who's supposedly
played with the Beatles you all know him
and I probably will think of his name as
soon as this is over and he sat down on
the drum set and he only moved his
visits I was so pretty pretty exactly
burnet pretty pricey yeah very pretty
purdie and he only moved his business
and it was a groove like I've never
heard it before so that is something and
I said in there and I just thought okay
we don't have that long time to go so
those are these experiences where you
just realized here this is some there is
a long tradition that is just still
alive and that I which I feel even
outside the world of jazz which I feel
is a life here because of all the you
know how music still fulfill fulfill to
function within the community I mean the
black church still is to this day
something that is so important and that
I even as an as an outsider just
realized when I walk through well
unfortunately i was here in winter so
all the doors were closed but when I
walk through Harlem honor on a Sunday on
a Sunday morning you could hear these
things and you just realized oh
that's what they hear every every Sunday
so this is I mean this is just and go to
go to a german church on a Sunday
morning there will be hardly anybody
present a and B it won't swing so you
don't learn that in church in Germany or
many other countries you learn a couple
of these things in church in italy or in
friends and some kecelakaan
trees where you have marching bands that
still have a community function you so
we're music actually has a function in
the community the story is a different
one you actually will you know it's
something comparable to this long living
tradition that that is a life here in
the United States so they bought that
now is that from classical concerts is
that just a cultural thing because of
what you were a team on the court he was
what he was talking about how in New
York the musician in around warning any
I mean as much as they feel so we're
just kind of be so again they don't know
just like your neighbor said I mean
they're scared because this audience
just stares and they don't know well
what does that mean yes that was
something that in the somehow and on 19
this has to do with a European art music
history you know where I mean from
history books we know that in that in
early opera everybody had dinner and
conversations and interrupted and
cheered during the upper and during
concerts people they're the same but at
one point in the 19th century that was
kind of well people didn't want that
anymore so it was ruled out there you
know no new rules were written for
concerts and when you go to the concert
you dress up and you are silent because
it's you know art is so important it's
like going to church and I mean it's
like going to church I'm saying that and
when I say that I realized that is also
different you go to church and nobody
will say Amen in the middle of something
you know to nobody will call and
response
probably had at one time but it must
have been long ago that is lost from
from most and I say Western European
traditions this call and response this
which is actually establishing a
community that is gone European all of
these European concerts are even church
or more about presenting and taking
about somebody who's presenting and it's
just an audience and it's not about give
and take and cons